I am also doing very well I'm in love
thank you thank you I tricked one I
don't know how he's like you're not like
other girls I'm like not yet
my parents like him which is crazy
because my dad's super overprotective
he's got four daughters so he's just
like playing dick goalie you don't have
to laugh he hates that joke too his
biggest fear was that one of us would
become sexually active before we're
married and some of us have been
activated
so that's can't take this back to Best
Buy I spilled some stuff on it keys are
sticky
that joke makes me sound like so much
more fun than I am I'm not a good time
like I've had sex with two people for if
you're Christian like I'm not you know I
don't do casual sex all my friends like
you don't know if you like it you've
never tried it I'm like vol so never
tried cottage cheese and I know that
[ __ ] looks nasty it's all wet and bumpy
I don't trust it okay I had a friend
tried to convince me of this argument
she goes you have to try a tailor there
is nothing more empowering than just
like banging a guy and leaving I'm like
yeah there is have you ever made a
dude's mom love you more than him that
is power I still talk to Sheila
I was so afraid when I was younger that
I would be bad at sex now that I'm older
it is so easy to be good at sex you guys
all you have to do is approach it with
the enthusiasm of a child you know just
put everything in your mouth like you're
four and your partner's made of Legos it
is not tough I didn't know who's gonna
work out with my boyfriend when we
started seeing each other because he is
completely fine
he was just good I don't mean he's
perfect like he was in a frat in college
she's basically a rescue yeah I turned
his life and his hat around but he has
no emotional baggage whatsoever and I
don't know if I like that you know those
who they've never been through anything
he goes to bed at night he's like oh
good night he's not like Oh dance like
he has none of that wakes up in the
morning like oh this morning he's not
like what why like he has none of the
stuff that I'm working through he
whistles you guys recreationally just
just walks around whistling like
everything's great I'm like do you know
who the president is like this is
disrespectful
a little suspicious he's like I'm in a
good mood I'm like we'll just so you
know every movie I've ever seen if
there's a dude whistling that guy's the
killer all right
I asked him on our first date I was like
is anything terrible ever happened to
you and he thought about it for a minute
he's like you know that face white guys
make or they're like oh I guess it has
been pretty good like the whole time hot
dog thanks Jesus like they're just stuck
after a minute he goes honestly no and I
was like oh my god because now I have to
be the terrible thing that happens to
him oh I'm gonna do it was gonna do it
anyway
I'm crazy all right I want to be the one
doesn't matter which one there are a lot
of ones you can be you can be the one
they marry the one that got away or the
one that set their car on fire it
doesn't matter just remember me all
right positive or negative Hall of Fame
Hall of Shame as long as my pictures on
the wall
I want to be a good thing I want to be
the reason he quits drinking but if I'm
not I'm gonna be the reason he starts
I'm not your happy ending I will be your
turning point okay I can feel some
people turning on me
so I'll tell you one last thing I didn't
realize how easy my boyfriend's life has
been until recently when I found out
he's never had sex in a car before yeah
now we're back on Team Taylor I'm like
never he's like no but I'm down I'm like
you're dead we're not brainstorming like
we have a home okay do you want desi no
car he's like I'm sure that sounds kind
of hot and I was like Oh
hop in Speed Racer let's kill a dream
because anybody who's had car sex knows
what I know that car sex is for children
or criminals it is for people outside
the law with nowhere to go if you've
never had sex in a car before that means
you've always had a place to bone that
is the epitome of privilege and I don't
care to know you if your ribs have never
been bruised by a center console we have
nothing to say to each other you guys
are great thank you